here is an insanely rare and beautiful
chess move that you have to play in your
lifetime opposite Checkmate is a
spectacular convergence of chest's most
memeable role and the glory of a
Victorious Checkmate yes
there we go every so often you'll see a
great apasan Checkmate going viral but
no opusan Checkmate can rival the
Masterpiece recently engineered by
Norwegian Grandmaster Yoon Ludwig Hammer
against his childhood friend and the
greatest chess player of all time Magnus
Carlson
check
are we seeing a trade oh 95 I did not
say that kind of Lucky that's not mate
oh it is mates
oh wow uh okay I'm going to let him make
me of course
okay nice